today is going to be based on joint
works with Petra Caputo former Canadian
accent we're all present in the audience
and then we're going to talk about this
object called random artists regulations
which I find it quite fascinating object
with very interesting properties so let
me start defining you what a lattice
translation is so I take the 0 n x 0 n
square and take all points of the two
inside this square and I'll consider
this point says just a point set and
I'll take a triangulation of this point
set which can be easily construct by
just adding edges one by one with the
property that the edge have endpoints in
this point set and contain no other
point of the point set + two edge can
only intersect at the endpoints it'll
keep doing this until you cannot add
eggs anymore and were left with a
picture like this where all phases of
your picture are triangles that's why I
called translations except from for the
external phase and it was the case that
the convex hull of a point set which
this case is the boundary of the N by n
square is always present in your
triangulation so that that's the object
I call a lattice translation one simple
and well-known fact that Oh first that's
not the only one our only lattice
language of the end by in the Box are
many of them and one special type of
translations I'd like you to keep in
mind it is very simple triangulations
where you have all the one by one
squares present in your minute
regulation and have this choice of unit
diagonals guy to put this one or this
one for each of the one by one squares
and this set of triangulation I'm going
to refer to as ground state
strangulations just because they are as
a reference for languages that we have
the smallest possible size for the edge
so that will be i'll refer to that
particular set of translations later
again so one sip of property that is
well known is that any triangulation to
take for the end by in the box had the
same number of edge and the same number
phase and these numbers are well known
and they have order n square so just
keep in mind that the size of our
instance of the problem is n square not
n so that's a lotta strangulation and
this problem this object has been looked
at in many different areas especially in
combinatorics and a lot of people come
from natal it's interesting counting how
many such strangulations are there for
at least get an asymptotic for the
number of triangulations of the N by n
box and despite many efforts this is not
known so no one knows exactly there is
no explicit formula for the number of
large strangulations and not even
asymptotic the writing synthetics are
known and this is in contrast with other
types of triangulations you may have run
into like triangulations of points in a
convex position a translation of a
convex polygon the number of such
regulations are well known are given by
Catalan numbers and also translations
from coming from the theory of random
apps which triangulations of the surface
of the sphere the rest of this fear with
exactly n vertices if you look at the
set of all such translations also the
number of sister agrees that explicit
formers for these things and this helps
a lot in analyzing this kind of objects
but such formulas such as empathic SAR
not available at the moment 4 life
strangulations and but one thing that we
know that they're exponentially many
such objects exponentially in n square
and this is easy to see from this
picture because it have two choice for
each of the unit diagonals here so that
at least two today n square and the best
bounds that are known as is too so there
is a lower bound that's exponential in
one point 42 and square due to KY red
cedar
and there is an upper bound it's
explained is 1.93 and square due to
metric vote and beds and as you see this
bouncer off by an exponential factor for
another so this in this bonehead already
have already being obtained with quite
involved and find studies of these
properties of this process but the right
answer is still not known in far from
rich so let's that's about counting me
just mention some basic profits of these
large strangulations if it's the first
time you see this object this process
this province may sounds quite you know
surprising and one properties no matter
which strangulation to take all
triangles have the same area and all
triangles have error half and no matter
the triangle can be this very simple
triangle here or a very long triangle
here they all have the same error half
in any lattice translation and this is
non speaks theorem and this is a
property that says that any triangle
whose endpoints are integers and that
contain no other point inside the
triangle in the edge of the triangle has
a area half so this means that if you
end up find a very long edge in your own
grave like this one then necessarily the
triangle contained at atmos must be very
thin at the height of the triangle must
be small so that the area is a half
another interesting property that's also
going to be useful for us is the
following so I'd like you to consider
the set of midpoints of the edge so take
any edge for them this edge here and
sees it to figure out that the midpoint
of this edge is somewhere around here if
you take a longer edge maybe a bit more
difficult to visualize where the
midpoint is but you can you can do it
and as an exercise you could try to
picture in your mind the midpoint of the
set of midpoints of all the edge just
try to put
to each edge and draw a dot at the
midpoint of that edge or try to
visualize this set it may sound a bit
strange question for me to ask you to do
but the fact is the set is very easy to
define very easy to see and that's the
set of midpoints it's very structured in
particular this set does not depend on
the triangulation if i change the
triangulation you have the same set of
mid points and the set of midpoint is
just described by this set which is the
set of points on the plane for which the
coordinates are either integer or half
integer but both coordinates cannot be
ended it cadets those of points of a
point set it is to see that any edge of
a triangulation of a lot strangulation
must have midpoint in this set because
the endpoints of the edge are integer
points so the midpoint better be a half
integer and to see that the opposite
that any such for any triangulation and
any such midpoint you find an edge with
that midpoint to just count the number
of points in this set and you see that
match exactly the number of internal
edges in a language just a counting
argument so that's a very interesting
property because it allows you to look
at strangulations using the language of
spin systems where your species are a
set of vertices of very species that is
just a set of midpoints these red points
and now you see a triangulation Sigma as
a collection of values Sigma X where X
range over midpoints and Sigma X denotes
the spin of the midpoint X and it's the
edge of Sigma whose midpoint is X ok so
you can see a large strangulations SP
system using this language of course
there are some challenge with trying to
use non techniques for analyzing spin
systems to the lattice translation the
sum of the challenge
that first there are unbounded many
spins for each midpoint special
midpoints away from the corners of the
of the box of the N by n box so that can
be or the n possible spins for 41 given
midpoint and another not important even
more striking challenge is that there
are many long local interactions going
on with the light Stranglers for example
if I take a triangle a very long
triangle like this one this green one of
course the edge of the triangle interact
with one another if they impose hardcore
constraints on the translation and even
though the midpoint of this to edge are
here around the middle the midpoint of
another edge of the trial could be very
far away so it is this can have a
Battaglia large dependence and hardcore
constraints on your translations and
even worse than that is that this this
interaction depends on the triangulation
it differs from traditional speed
systems where you had usually have a
name utonium that defines which which
spin tracks that which which other spins
with neighbors but in this case no the
interaction depends on the on the
triangulation this makes makes it quite
challenging to use some known techniques
for analyzing not strong glitches let's
the property i would like to mention so
what I'm going to look at now when look
at random such objects and are going to
reduce the following measure on largest
regulation I'm going to just right here
for simplicity so for each
strangulations Sigma we are going to
have a major new of Sigma which is there
is a normalizing constant make it a
probability measure then have the Sun or
than the Sun
have a parameter lambda to the sum over
all midpoints X of the size of the edge
of Sigma whose midpoint is X so this
quartz the here is just the sum of the
length of the edge of our triangulation
so the total edge length of your
translation and to do some probability
measure mew of signal which is
proportional to lump that this parameter
lambda that's some positive parameter to
the total edge length of a jungle age
and just for concreteness i'll take the
length of an edge to be the l1 length it
just convenient in the industry so we
create see that a free case for lambda
that you can submit immediately spot if
lambda is more than one your
triangulation who prefer short edge if
lambda is bigger than one you're going
to pay for long edge and if from this
equal to one then you have uniformly
random strangulations so that's the
probability measure going to look at and
you're going to find a Markov chain over
lata strangulations that given a lot
strangulation there on the left the
markov chain has transitioned let's
follow you are going to pick an edge an
internal edge uniformity random which
means you just pick a midpoint
uniformity angle for example that red
one there and then you this meet this
edge must be a diagonal of a
quadrilateral so these two triangles
that contain the edge if this
quadrilateral is strictly convex then
you can replace remove this edge and add
the opposite diagonal and you get a
valid regulation and you do that with
probability proportional to the
condition probability of having this
edge given all the other edges are
present in fixed so just do global
dynamics or hit best dynamics on this
but if you end up choosing an edge that
is a diagonal for quite a lot that is
not strictly convex like in this case
then you cannot remove this agent now
add the order
diagonal cuts do not create a value
triangulation so in this case you just
don't do anything and suppress the move
just stay put okay so that's your markov
chain and the only thing you need to
show in order to show that this Markov
chain converts to the the measure just
introduced is help surely the mac of
change irreducible so you have to show
that between any two triangulations i
can transform on translation into the
other by just performing these flip
operations and this is of course not
completely trivial but the property that
you need is the following if once
transformed the problems of our ones if
the transponders from one triangulation
to not regulation what to do is take one
triangulation and look at the longest
edge of that language so the longest
edge must always be flippable and the
reason is the quadrilaterals that they
edged in the quadrilateral around this
edge cannot be larger than the size of
the edge itself got that edge the
longest so it necessarily means that if
this quadrilateral which i forgot to say
but if an edge is flip about this
quadrilateral must actually be a
parallelogram not only studio to convex
with the parallelogram in this case we
have that this is a dis poem
constrictive you have this parallelogram
it's strictly convex so it can actually
flip the longest edge since all the
other edges of the crazy vato are not
larger than that edge so it has to be a
strictly convex quadrilateral there are
other properties you need is that not
only that the longest edge is flippable
but the canonical two possible case
either the longest edge is of this form
is a unit diagonal which means we are
back to this ground state set of co
triangulations where we have all the
units squares and the unit diagonals in
the whole picture that are shown in the
beginning or if you're not not in this
situation if you have a longer stretch
it's not even diagonal what happens this
edge is flipping and strictly decrease
in size after flipping it so in order to
create a path between two triangulations
just take the longest edge of one
regulation
look at the new longest edge flip it and
keep it doing that eventually seems to
at each step you decrease the side of
the edge strictly eventually gets to a
ground state strangulation you do the
same with the other triangulation and
once both I reduce to ground state from
glacier can just flip unit diagonal to
match them up so we have a path between
any two ND two triangulations in this
case okay so that's that's the object to
want to look at there are many
interesting questions one could ask
about this this Markov chain of this
object our main interest in studying is
object was to look at the mixing time of
discover dynamics and the main reason
that it's already appears in the papers
by the people from coming to olives by
Kravitz eager they suggest look at the
mix in time of this global dynamic
fellows strategy in the case of lambda
equals one the case of uniformly random
triangulations as I strategy to come up
with a polynomial time algorithm to
approximate the number of translations
but I we see that they the mixing time
is interesting want to look if even for
all the values of lambda actually this
translation shows quite this lattice
translation so quite interesting
behaviors for many for different values
of London but of course there are many
other questions you could ask besides
mixing time like the what's the typical
length of an edge of a given edge
whether there are detailed correlations
and all other questions are not just are
not say much about this let me just give
you an idea how this object behaves so
let me open this ok so this is
there is a 50 by 50 triangulation and
the ship is complaining that's a 50 by
50 turn out now the things compare now
okay there's a 50 by 50 ambulation just
taken a bateria one and now i'm going to
start if you do let me know and now you
know i'm going to run the markov chain
with lambda equals 2.9 so the markov
chains Ronnie doing this flip dynamics
is global dynamics I just told you and
lambda here is point nine so that we're
favoring short edge and what you can
observe that every now and then some
longest edge shows up just because there
are so many possibilities something
started growing a bit and these are the
region that get a bit darker because
this edge know that longer the edges the
thinner the triangle is so they have
more edge close to the one another so
get darker image senior in a simulation
but if you focus your eye in one region
for hip here and just wait a bit to see
that even if some longest edge shows up
it washes away very quickly so it
suggests that the Markov chain should be
fast mixing and that and also if you
look at regions on your on your
simulation at a far away you suspect to
throw the simulation that they evolved
roughly independence they don't affect
one another much so we'd expect details
relations and all such nice properties
but it's I have to tell you that
actually all this is open for anybody
triangulations and for in for the
general case of just assuming lambdas
more than one and in our in our first
paper in this in this topic what we show
that if you take lambda is small enough
then for lumber is modern off you can
follow lamblia small enough you can show
that the mix in time is fast actually
the mixing time is as fast
as the diameter of the chain so can't be
faster than that and it showed the key
of correlations we can show uniquely and
softer of the gives measure can show
many many properties for lambda
sufficiently small but we believe this
through the hall holds for all lambda is
more than one but this is to open so now
let me take this this picture and change
the value of lambda for you so I'm going
to put lambda equals to 1.1 and then we
let the Markov chain run a bit and now
I'm going to see that the picture gets
much different than before in particular
knows London's bigger than one so we are
such favorite longer edge so so some
long edge to start showing up the eggs
around that are kind of aligned to that
edge forced to be aligned this gives
room between them for longer edge to
stop creeping in and keep going and this
creates a big region of ads that start
to get aligned with one another and of
course but this ad starts growing
different areas of your picture didn't
add some moments you have this big close
then they start cry crash within another
dick they cannot grow anymore even if
they want so this suggests that Markov
chain start to get stuck in some
configurations and actually to get this
even clear if that was needed I can I
can just do the phonograph take Ed's
that oriented in this way I know caller
them with one caller excellent in this
way a call with another caller and
they're going to get a picture like this
and this blue and red regions they later
see that the boundary of this region's
is always horizontal and vertical lines
so have this very simple to describe
boundary but you know if you should
suspect that form the beginning one the
measure would concentrate on
configurations where most of the region
is of one color and would find other
colleges in some
scattered small areas of your offering
abandon box but of course for example
this this red region will fight a bit
hard until it gets convinced to become
blue and the reason is another transform
this guy into blue I have to take all
this longest edge reduce them to the
smallest possible size 2 unit diagonals
then flip to the other direction and
then let them grow again and this of
course costs a lot for the markov chain
to do that so it's going to take a long
time to do that change so that's a the
picture for lung the bigger than one so
we expect that markov chain will be is
lowly mixing we can ever we can give
exponential bounds on the markov chain
for this case for all of the bigger than
one but we're still far from the right
answer and not just before continuing
the top just erase the colors and i'm
going to set lambda and i'm going to do
an experiment here usually don't do this
but i'll start with this very crash then
very blocked triangulation i'm going to
set a level e coast one and then you see
what happens b and then you're going to
soon if you look at simulation for a
while you were seated well on the equals
one even if you're not favoring long
short edge even if the Congress had
blocked but we still see that you it
slowly forgetting what the blocking
configuration is and actually if I had
more time for a talk I could leave this
for half an hour it would be enough for
you to see to completely forget about
the blocking configuration had seen
before so you still have some longer
stretches
different ones you get some longest
apparently longest edge but they are not
they don't create as rigid regions as in
the case lambda equals only they show up
but they gets washed away after some
reasonable time as long as the long ones
you're saying no there'd be a bit
shorter so yeah so what I can say about
this what we know about this case is
nothing to deserve that that's all i
have about lambda equals one we don't
know anything we suspect that the mixing
time would be given by some polynomial
but not with a larger power than and the
case lambda is more than one let's just
important number so I'm going to just
continue with the talk I'm going to let
this running on the background so
remember how the blocking configuration
was and then at the end we can we can
see what whether we see something from
the blocking configuration so let me say
that our main focus was the mixing time
of the global dynamics I'm not going to
talk much about that problem because
that will show up in the next stop by
fabio and his explain better these
things what I want to concentrate here
is I said that with our first results
was for lump that sufficient snore than
one but expect the same behavior to hold
for all of this more than one but the
techniques we use to prove the results
for lambda sufficient is more than one
for example to prove the calculations we
implement just a careful but standard
fermentation of a pious argument that
already showed the calculation problem
the sufficiently small and you don't
expect you know the pies argument to
work all the way to learn this more than
one so we need to develop new techniques
but no lattice strangulations tend to
fight hard they don't like you to get
results about them and for example there
are many properties that are very useful
knives of species that do not hold forth
strangulations for example
kg does not hold which quite surprised
you would expect that conditioner some
heads being small would increase the
probability of other heads being small
but you can come up with varies examples
where this phase so so what do I'm going
to explain here is one technique that we
know that gives some information about
the case of all um there's more than one
ok that's what I'm going to concentrate
for the less of the talk and this is a
construction of a lap not function on
lata strangulations so the function a
bit involved so let's go slowly first
let me generalize the problem I'm going
to look at lattice strangulations with
constraint edge so I'm adding this red
edge and I'm taking out my measure on
triangulations condition on this edge
being present and it we also know that
the Markov chain is still be reducible
given any set of constraints so within
this set where the concealer president
Markov chain connecting it to
triangulations within the set by flips
and this this Lyapunov function will be
a function you have you can see this
functions the following you take a
triangulation say imagine regression on
the floor and now picture it midpoint on
top of the translation and the apple of
function give some height values and
value for each midpoint of your
triangulation and what this lebanon funk
should tell you is that this value if it
grows up too much this value tends to
decrease let me let me explain how the
function is defined so I'm going to take
the phone for each midpoint I'm going to
have a value and let's focus on a
midpoint X and given the constraints I
draw in blue the smallest possible edge
moods midpoint is X and satisfy the
constraint does not violate the
constraint so if the constraints are not
there the smallest possible edge of mid
point X would beat the horizontal edge
but this edge cannot be present kodokan
strange the red edge
so the small as possible age of mid
point x is this one now take this edge
this edge may not belong to a
triangulation just take this as a
reference edge and then you take our
edge of your triangulation Sigma that
intersect or cross that edge so these
same just look at my triangulation now
we're just looking at the edge of the
triangle is that cross the blue edge and
now your function the value of the
function at the point X will be the sum
over those edge the edge that cross the
blue edge of alpha it's another
parameter introducing to the power of
the size of the edge let's cross the
blue edge minus the size of the blue
edge so the side of the bridge is not
important just normalization important
across summing exponential factors based
on the length of each edge that crossed
the blue edge and this alpha is going to
be a value that's bigger than one but
such that alpha times lambda is more
than one so its bigger than one but not
much but you can always find such alpha
if lambda is truth is more than one so
this gives a value for the midpoint X
and a cities as a height sorry the sub X
rose for side what is the X X is the
midpoint that the chose yeah so it's for
each X I have a value leads on that on
the edge that cross that the smallest
edge blue edge that has midpoint X and
now so let me just mention two useful
properties of discourse and discuss it
sounds very strange at first but but
there are some interesting fact about it
the first fact is the larger the value
of the function at X kind of indicates
how far away the local configuration
around X is from the minimum value so
just to take an example suppose that the
blue edge was in the triangulation this
means that no other edgewood across the
blue heads besides the blue edge
so this funk should be just the blue
edge of alpha to the blue edge mine's
the blue edge zero so to be one this
function is one if the blue edge belongs
the triangulation so if the edge at
midpoint X is at the minimum failure if
the blue Ed's not present then certainly
the edge of the translation that has
midpoint X cross the bridge it cross at
X and this edge has size larger than the
blue edge where the blood is that small
as possible for that midpoint so
immediately you give a fact that's
bigger than one so in the fact and in
every time you take your triangulation
and do flip an edge in such a way that
this edge increases in size the value of
the function can own increase and the
reason is anytime an edge of your
triangulation cross the blue edge if
this edge is flippable and we increase
its size it's still cross the bridge
that's just geometric property not
completely trivial but but that's an
interesting property of this of these
crossings so that that's given pitch and
why the dysfunction is useful and let me
just state the theorem for this gap
enough function so the theorem is the
following so if for every lump does more
than one you can find an alpha bigger
than one such that this function is at
the apple of function for every X and
this means that they exist a constant C
depending only on lambda such that for
all triangulation Sigma for all midpoint
X if the function at x is bigger than C
then after one step of the Markov chain
the expected value of the function
decrease so this means that if you again
go back to the picture of the
triangulation who preached on the floor
and this the value of the function for
each X being some height function top of
this picture my never a point gets above
the value see it has a drift down so it
behaved as
super Mattingly so this means that this
function pointwise tends to be close to
two series so that that's the main fact
and since at least in a high level
picture the value of the funk the larger
the value kind of indicates that the
configuration is further away from the
local configuration the minimum possible
local configuration on that midpoint it
tells you that the configurations
pointwise tends to be close to the
minimum that's what it to indicate so my
goal here that I want to tell you two
things about this function the first
thing is why the exponential form why
it's useful and the second thing I want
to tell you is just one idea one
ingredient on how to prove that sexually
open off function let me just and one
important things are for application
it's very important that actually this
level of function works for any set of
constraints arbitrary constants can be
as large as you want as strange as what
it works stupid applause function and
now so it works for triangles of not
only the end by in a box what of any
shape could be instead of square it will
be the rectangle you could be a
trapezoid it could be any lattice
polygon even non convex and the Franklin
still works as a level of function just
to a level of function so its robust in
this sense and DHA is quite important
for applications so let me just quickly
tell you why the exponential form that
and this is to solve one problem to take
care of one problem of lattice
translation that an edge like this one
that can be flipped and flipped decrease
in size can increase the bateria large
values for example in this case this
edge has length 1 and increase to very
large length and this length could be a
bateria large by taking these two
endpoints and put as far away as you
want could be of order n so one king an
edge can go for size 12 size of order n
in one flip of course you pay expand
ential price to do
flip but no it would increase a lot the
value of the function if if the flip
happens and the nice properties the
following let me just quickly go through
this is that just look at the
contribution expect the contribution of
an edge so still have this edge which is
flippable and it increase if flipped and
you want to compare the expected value
you want to look at the spectacle
tribution of this edge well just look at
alpha to the length of this edge just to
simplify forget about the sum and
anything just look at alpha to the side
of this edge and how this value change
how the what's expected value of this
after a possible flip and the important
things that if you look if you say that
e and f at the length of the edge of the
parallelogram surrounding the the red
the green edge then the side of these
edges exact f minus e in l1 or and if
you flip it it becomes f + e so if you
write down the expected value of the
edge you just get to know alpha to the F
minus e times the probability that you
don't flip alpha to death place the
times the probability to flip and if you
factor out lambda 2 F minus E and not
just go quickly what you get is at this
term and this term should stare for one
minute just you have alpha to the F
minus EF minus is just a value of the
edge you had before the flip then have a
term here that's 1 plus lambda 2 e
lambda is more than 1 and 2 e is the
amount the edge change the size it could
be very large but the latter it is
because it is just one so it doesn't
harm you and have this other term that
has an alpha lambda 2 to eat but you are
setting alpha to be small so that alpha
land is more than 1 so this also doesn't
have you so it's what says is that this
function up two constants just alpha to
the F minus e it only depends on the
value of the edge before flipping so it
doesn't matter for how big the edge
becomes this dysfunction absorbs the
impact of this this this change and it
allows you to control
this this strange case so that's why one
reason why this alpha to the size of the
edge it's kind of handy the other thing
I want to say is is how to prove that
this function is a level of function let
me just before doing that let me just
mention a much simpler function you
could you could come up with done it
with join we can just for example drop
the Sun and you could try to think
whether I can just say that the value of
the function at X is just alpha to the
size of X you could just ask yourself I
cannot just take the function in the
simpler form and the reason is of course
this function would not be pointwise a
super martingale if it gets bigger than
see because edge that are increasing in
size that can be flipped and increased
cannot increase the value of the
function so if X was a midpoint whose
edge Sigma X is increasing so this at
that point no matter how large the
function is it would increase in
expectation to crisp it never decrease
that point unless you change the
triangulation make that edge decrease so
that's missing this is to tell you that
you need some sort of averaging in order
to allow that for each midpoint the
value of the function behaves a
submartingale point wise in the end and
we were like and that's why we're
introducing these discusses in order to
it as a way to come up with this
averaging let me just it's the less
light of technical things I just want to
tell you why one reason why this
function behaves us or one ingredient on
how to prove this function behave as a
super martingale and it's a nice
partition on the toner triangulation so
well partition the triangles of a
triangulation as following for any
triangle for example this one here you
just going to just traverse the
triangles and I Traverse along the
largest edge of the triangle so for the
dryer go to this
triangle from this triangle go to this
one going keep going and peer across
this orange edge and when I cross the
orange edge I go back right because
that's the largest edge of the two
triangles and at moment I stop and each
edge that gets mapped to the orange edge
becomes the part of the partition
centered at this orange edge so what it
is partitions your triangles it's set
and one interesting that if you look at
this orange edge it's always a
decreasing edge edge that you if you
flip you decrease it because it has to
be an edge that's the largest in both
triangles containing it so it has to be
decreasing so all decreasing edge are as
I call centers of dis partitions and
another nice properties that are
increasing edge added the boundary
because increasing edge edge that are
not the largest in both triangles so
each of these drugs must be mapped to
different edge so that's that's that's a
quite useful partition because now if
you want to do your function centered at
a midpoint here and this blue line is
just the smallest edge with mid point is
that and want to look at all ads that
cross this blue edge now if you look at
the back edge these edges increasing and
the geometric fact that if this edge is
increasing the two centers of the
partition that contain that edit edges
in the boundary also cross the pledge
so that that's fact is is variously the
proof God says that for any increasing
edge let's cross the bridge I can find
to decreasing edge that also crossed and
this pudding quizzes is a larger than
the increasing edge necessary larger
because the way I construct you always
cross the largest edge of a triangle so
you end up in the largest edge of your
partition so this allows you to say ok
but if this edge increase it increased
the value of the function at this point
but I have to edge that even larger and
have a bigger effect on the airplane or
function and data also waiting to be
decreased let's see so that's how they
did the knowledge of the goal is just to
look at the edge that increase associate
with the edge that decrease in such
centers of partitions and using many
other things you can establish the
episode that this this function is
behaved as a yappin off function just to
conclude I have just the less slide just
want to say some quick consequence of
this so this this type of functions you
can use to show for example that edge
have exponential tail so if look at the
stationary measure fix at the midpoint X
and look what's the size what's the
probability at that edge at the midpoint
x is bigger than the minimum possible
value plus some L decays exponentially
in L not only this works for the
stationary major but also works for the
measure induced by the Markov chain if
you let the Markov chain runs for long
enough time so I would like to say that
the the Lyapunov function implies that
you have conversions of local measures
in the sense that if i look at the fix
square of some fixed size in the middle
of your n by n square and i look at all
the edge that intersect is square in the
left n goes to infinity i would like to
say that this lachlan function pie that
is the measure on this small box
conversed but that's we are not yet able
to prove that but at least are able to
prove tightness of local of this measure
so the
no that is subsequently meets exist but
you don't know that at least we can't
prove that they are unique is only one
another thing that we can show that if
you give me any set of constraint edge I
battaglia large as strange as you want
and you give me a midpoint that's not
part of the constraint the double
function implies that the probability
that appointed a stationary measure give
on the set of constraint that that edge
is indeed really minimal value is
bounded below bound away from zero so
this see depends only on on lambda
that's also quite useful fact and also
there are some structural properties you
can get from last regulations for
example can get that there are top to
bottom crossings of your end by in the
Box composed of paths of small triangles
triangles of all edges more than some
given constant depending on lambda but
the fourth it gives a lot of things but
doesn't is not yet enough to prove the
calculations and mixing time results in
some more particular case for example if
will not look at n by n box but and bike
a box where case fixed and you just let
n goes infinity keeping k fix then you
can prove much more but this will be the
topic of the next talk so i'll just stop
here thanks
the boundaries is always a rather ugly
candy making a torus out of it so you
get rid of the inches we certainly would
lambda less than 1 it shouldn't look
terribly different yes you can you can
you can wrap around many times right and
looks like a structure space for them
the bigger than one well in any fix all
of the following there's more than one I
agree but for lumber billions very
strange because this edge will be able
to tip grow indefinitely lambda less
someone you probably find yourself in
familiar territory mm-hmm greater than
one you might get something bizarre
happen again people been able to come to
continental triangulations
exactly okay for n by n don't remember
exactly but the paper where there is a
lower bound the Cabot's ego they have
some competition for four counting force
for some values n and I don't believe it
gets much luck it doesn't get larger
than seven so you know its exploration
today is square so it's looking it's
even less than seven but it but the SS I
want commit threatens so you mentioned
that the result you have done function
it it holds for any lattice it holds no
no I it holds for you take the two and
take any polygon whose endpoints a verte
substitute give me even non convex and
and then it you take a translation of
the point that I inside this it's
polygon then then it holds not for any
lattice fine lads would lose many of
these properties we'd have to prove that
by the prophets are about midpoints it
still holds
can we see the results of your beautiful
yes I was waiting someone to ask and
they used to be a big block on earth
okay so it's that it took less than an
hour so it just looks like there are
some long edge but doesn't resemble much
anymore the structure we start with it
does look at this configuration you
don't see these kind of things in point
nine do wanna change nine